you saw what happened
gutted uh nauseous
i grew up coming into you know the
spring mountains you know mount
charleston was a playground for me
growing up i got married right up here
at cathedral rock
um and now you know working here and
managing our visitor and volunteer
programs it's
it's devastating for me just just
driving up i i was
holding back tears
it's decades of history now pretty much
gone
gone like completely gone
i mean just
seeing what it looks like now that it
that's it's not just a little fire it's
a it's gone
and this was a gathering place
um you know not just for
visitors coming up but it was a
gathering place for
you know our community the residents up
here all the folks that work up here
through the forest service and you know
our southern american conservancy folks
it it's a place where you would go it
was a place where you'd relax it was a
place where you could connect with other
people that worked you know with you in
the mountains and had those similar
values of keeping visitors safe and
keeping the mountain healthy and
i i just i don't know what's going to
happen next it's
very sad very sad for everyone up here